The top 1% of business owners aren't
smarter than you. They do things
differently. And that's what I'm
explaining in this video. I'm Alexi. I
own acquisition.com. It's a portfolio of
companies that generate hundreds of
millions of dollars per year in revenue.
And so, I've seen a lot of different
patterns across businesses that we both
invested and scaled in or some that we
turn down. If you feel stuck, it's
because what got you from 0 to 100,000
or $100,000 to a million or a million to
10 million or 10 million to 30 million
isn't going to be the thing that gets
you to the next level. and you're
probably working on something that was
once very important but is no longer.
So, to make this real, I'm going to give
you three examples of my own business
experience of what I thought the
business I was in versus the one I was
actually in. So, in the very beginning,
I was into fitness. I got into it
thinking that my life was going to be
about, what workouts we were going to
be, and how I was going to structure the
weights and the intensity. And then, as
soon as I actually got into the
business, I realized that the biggest
issue is most people don't even show up
to the gym, all of my attention was
like, "Oh my god, I have to get people
first in the door, and how do I get them
to stay?" and how do I run this
profitably when I've got rent, I've got
trainers, I've got equipment that
breaks. And all of a sudden, I was like,
"Oh my god, I thought I was going to be
in the
scientific fitness business when in
reality, I was in the sales and
marketing business." One of the easiest
ways to identify what business you're
really in is to zoom all the way out to
the people who are already a hundred
steps ahead of you. Not just one or two
steps, but like a hundred steps. And the
reason for that is because if I said if
you just look at someone who's one or
two steps ahead of you, you should do
what they do. The thing is is that
they're one or two steps ahead of you
and they're probably going to get lost,
too. But if you look at the people who
are all the way at the top, typically
it's because they figured out something
that you haven't figured out. If you
look at the biggest fitness businesses
that are gyms, most of them are
basically in the sales and marketing
business. They have absolutely
mechanized the ability of getting people
in the door. Their general managers for
each location are just people who have
membership quotas who are driving sales
day in and day out. And so for me, I
never even sold a poor. I didn't know
what a lead was. I didn't know what
email marketing was. I didn't know any
of this stuff. And the thing is is I
signed a lease and 30 days later I had
to come up with $5,000. And I'm like,
how am I going to do that? When I was
begging people to buy to buy my gym
memberships, that was a form of sales,
not good sales, but it was a form of
sales nonetheless. All of a sudden,
through repetition, I was like, "Okay,
so I have to have these consistent
conversations that get people to buy.
And if I do that more effectively, then
all of a sudden, I make more money."
Okay, cool. So, this is really important
to this business because believe it or
not, people don't wake up someday and
say, "You know what? I'm going to sign
up for a gym membership." Doesn't
usually happen that way. Usually, they
got to get interrupted. So, they have to
get interrupted with some sort of ad.
And that then reminds them that they're
not in the shape that they want to be.
Or they put on their clothes in the
morning. They're like, "Oh my god, I
can't close this thing." But still, they
don't just say, "Oh, I'm going to call
the gym up." Not usually how it happens.
Instead, again, it's other people
stopping them in the parking lot being
like, "Hey, do you want a free workout
or thing?" or showing up to their office
of work and saying, "Hey, we made these
protein muffins. Hey, while you're
eating these muffins of ours, can I tell
you about what semi-private training
might do for you?" You have to get in
front of people in order to ultimately
bring them into the gym. The other
problem with gyms that I didn't know I
was in is that basically no one sticks
with gyms. Now, there's a very small
select group of people who are hardcore
lifters who do absolutely get obsessed
with gyms. But here's the crazy part
that everyone in the industry doesn't
tell you. They are such a small
percentage that they're the ones who
actually take up all the space in the
gym. And if the amount of people that
actually were subscribed to the gym, all
of them came, no gym model would work at
10, 20, $30 a month. Like if you
actually had people pay who only used
it, your gym membership would have to be
something like $200 to $300 a month,
which just so happens to coincide with
with the vast majority of service-based
gyms. what cross trainining facilities
and boot camps and semi-private training
facilities, all of those have clients
who all show up and that's why those
prices are where they're at. Even a
business like Crunch or Planet Fitness,
they have $10 a month memberships, but
they still have like five or six% per
month of their customers who turn out.
So that's like half the customers per
year are leaving out the door. If you've
got thousands of customers and you lose
half them every year, guess what else?
You need a machine for generating
another few thousand customers to fill
up the bucket. These very large
companies know how to train sales staff,
recruit sales staff, market across
different channels to get customers in
the door. And once I figured that out,
my gyms started growing. But until I
did, I was like lost. Might be like,
"Okay, so every business has to be a
marketing and sales business." Uh, kind
of. And so then I got into the
supplement business. So this business
for sure is about what's inside of the
bottle. So I got Dr. Cash. He's the
smartest human being that I know who's a
PhD biochemist. Got his, you know, PhD
when he was 21 years old. He also did
the stacks for Olympic teams and he has
a national log press record. So I was
like, this guy is going to come up with
the most efficacious product, the best
ingredients. And I just said, listen,
you make the best thing you could
possibly make, I'll figure out how to
sell it. That was the business that I
thought I was in. The actual business
that I was in with supplements is
actually in the brand and distribution
business. The ugly secret of the
supplement business, at least in the
United States, is that if something
actually works, it's most of the time
illegal because if something works a
little bit, then typically if you put a
lot of it in, it works a lot of it. Now,
I think supplements are good for, you
know, filling up holes, nutritional
holes in people's diet so that they can
get some of these other, you know,
minerals or whatever. But the thing is
is that if you're a customer, when you
have two different proteins that have
the exact same calories and macros, what
gets you to buy? The brand. And so,
because every single supplement supplier
has access to the same ingredients more
or less as everyone else, and the
research studies that are out there,
anyone who says that they know the
research, the customers certainly don't
know what the research is, nor do they
really care. What they really care about
is how good does it taste and do I feel
cool when I drink it or eat it? And I
was like, "Oh my god, this is not at all
what I spent my entire time building
this business to be." Then I had to
learn all this stuff about brand. Now, I
didn't know anything about brand at that
time. And so that business kind of got
to what I would consider like a direct
sales model, but what I really missed
was the cool factor. I didn't understand
how to make my products cool. And if
somebody's gonna buy a creatine for me
versus a creatine that's 14 bucks and
mine's 60, why are they gonna buy it? I
didn't have a good answer to that
question. And not only that, I didn't
have distribution that was convenient.
In the beginning for a business like
this, you can sell online to consumers.
They cover the shipping and stuff, but a
lot of times people still like buying
supplements in person because it's very
easy. You don't have to pay the extra
shipping. The business that I thought I
was in was a combination of sales and
making a great product. But the business
I was really in was a brand and
distribution business. And you might be
like, "Okay, so that business was maybe
different." But the third time he'll
definitely get it right. You would hope
that, but I I didn't. The next business
that I had that I wasn't good at was my
first software company. At this point,
when I got into it, I was like, "Okay,
listen. I can market and sell this
thing. That's all that's going to
matter." Because I had, you know, again,
I learned I hit everything with the
marketing and sales hammer because that
was what I was good at. But when I got
in the software business, I realized
that you could sell software really,
really easily because most software
solves a problem that's pretty easy to
describe. And the technology is supposed
to remove a lot of pain. The problem is
that as soon as someone logs in and it
doesn't solve that problem or it solves
that problem by introducing even more
pain into their lives, which is very
common, they then immediately hate it
and you by default. I thought I was in
the marketing and sales business yet
again when in reality I was in the
product business and I didn't know
anything about product from like a
software. I didn't know how to I didn't
know how to write code. I didn't know
what UX or design is. Like I'm still not
that good at design. The whole thing was
just kind of like screwed from the from
the onset. I didn't have any of the
talent and my strategy was not around
product. So the fundamental issue with
that business was that the product
wasn't good enough to deliver on the
promise and the problem was I needed to
make a better product and I didn't know
how. I at the time hired an outsourced
development team, right? And so I just
had them build the product. I was like,
"Yeah, do all the code stuff and, you
know, ship it back to me." But the issue
that I ran into was a couple things.
Number one is that I literally aligned
myself with someone who had a
disincentive to do a good job. So think
about this. They bill hourly and so
their incentive is to charge as much as
humanly possible and do as little as
possible in that period of time and just
keep me on long enough that I don't
cancel. Now, the longer you work with an
outsource development shop, the harder
it is to leave them because they have
all these developers who are dedicated
to your account and they're all read up
on the code. You're like, "Well, I can't
switch now because they already have
five or 10 or 20 developers that are
allocated to me." And here's the even
worse part. Let's say that you're still
really good at marketing and sales.
Guess what happens next? They see how
much money you're making. They own the
damn software, right? So, they can see
that you're making money. And you know
what's crazy is that I I noticed as we
kept making more money, my fees just
kept going up. Wild. Almost so much that
I was like, "Wait, where's my profit?"
At the end of the day, the dev shop was
more or less taking advantage of us. And
because I had no technical proficiency,
nor did I have a co-founder who was
really technical because you can't
absolutely have a business like this.
Somebody's got to know how to code,
right? Somebody's got to understand
technology. And I didn't know it. And I
didn't have anybody else. and
specifically I have anybody else who is
incentivized to help because in the
software business you can make the
promise of good fast cheap and people
are going to buy but you have to fulfill
that promise and that's fundamentally
what makes that business so hard but
also so lucrative when you get it right
and so I learned that lesson too late I
ended up selling that company to
somebody who did have a full in-house
dev team and I had built because of my
sales and marketing ability still a
pretty decentsized distribution base
that he could then leverage with his
software and continue to expand the
business so that worked out. Okay. So,
I'll give you another example of what
business are you really in. So, I talked
to a guy recently who is in the M&A
world, so mergers and acquisitions, and
he was buying up plumbing businesses.
And so, he bought up a plumbing
business. And I was like, "Okay, well,
what's limiting the business?" And he
said, "I can't find good plumbers." So,
I was like, "Well, what's your system
for getting plumbers?" And honestly, he
didn't have one. And so, I was like,
"Okay, dude. If we think about what the
product of this business is, when you're
in a service business, the product is
the service. Meaning the people who
deliver the service are the thing you
sell. And the margin of the business is
the difference between what you have to
pay them and what you get to charge for
their work. Our acquisition process to
scale the business doesn't have to be
customerf facing because you've got
phones ringing off the hook. There's
already tons of demand. There's
insufficient supply. And so the question
is, what are you doing to out market
your competition for talent? I
introduced to him a concept that I love
to talk about, which is the cost of
acquiring talent relative to the
lifetime gross profit per employee. All
right, it's a lot of letters. Basically,
this is how much it cost you to get
people. This is how much you make from
them. And so I said, "Well, how much
does it how much do you make from a
plumber per year in gross profit? So
revenue minus what you pay them. What do
you make?" He said, "Probably about, you
know, $300,000 a year." And I was like,
"Okay." I was like, "So, what are you
willing to spend to get another
plumber?" He's like, "Well, I think we
have like a $500 referral thing if any
of the guys refer somebody else." And I
was like, "Okay." So, think about how
wild this is. You're willing to pay
$500 for
$300,000 per year. This is per year for
from your plumbers. I was like, "Does
this feel a little bit
low?" Of course it did. It's it's
insanely low because the thing is is
that if you're a smart competitor, what
am I going to do? I'll be like, "Well,
shoot. I'll pay
$30,000." So, all of a sudden, if I
offered $30,000 to everyone in my staff,
if they can go get somebody, what do you
think's going to happen? They're
probably going to find more plumbers for
me. But guess what else I can do with
$30,000? I could also say, "You know
what? I'm willing to spend that in paid
ads or in recruiting or
headunting of people who just go and
post people from firm to firm. How do I
know if it's going to work out? Well, if
you're doing a referral bonus, you can
say that it's after they're productive
at month six. Now, you've got somebody
who did the referral who's super
invested in making sure that it works
out. Most recruiting firms have 90-day
clauses to make sure that if the person
doesn't work out in the first 90 days,
they'll swap them out for free. That's
pretty typical offer. If you're running
ads, you don't have to worry about
either of those because it's just the
cost of the ads. The question is if the
one thing that's limiting this business
is that he doesn't have enough plumbers.
Literally everything that he does with
his time that is not about creating an
acquisition system for talent is the
thing that's limiting the business. I'll
give you a different example and the
reason I keep giving you these examples
is because it happens in every business
and this is typically what keeps
business owners stuck. you started doing
something, maybe it worked and then it
stops working. But you think, "Oh, I
need to keep doing this thing or do more
of this thing." When sometimes that's
the truth, but a lot of times it's just
that the game changed or the real
constraint of the business is not the
thing you think it is. So, I was talking
to a media company, super large
YouTuber, big creator, right? And I
said, "Well, what's the goal?" And they
said, "We want to, you know, build, you
know, make more money." I said, "Okay,
great. So, what do you think it is right
now?" And they're like, "Well, you know,
right now," and just to give you
context, they're a way bigger channel
than me. Very big. Many millions, tens
of millions. I said, "What are you doing
right now?" They're like, "Well, we
think that we've really mechanized our
process of creating content and you
know, we think that we can get this
these new levels of efficiency in the
content creation." And I was like,
"Okay, so out of a hundred compared to
the marketplace, what would you guys
rate your your content at right now?"
So, what's funny is that like they would
they were like, "I think we're like
maybe a 90." But I'm like, "God, like if
you just do percentiles here, like your
0, but everybody when it's your own
game, you know much about it. You've
forgotten more than people who are have
been in this for two years know about
it. You guys are probably like a 99 out
of a hundred on marketing. The issue
with your business, despite the hundreds
of millions of impressions per week that
you're generating, is that you're just
not making that much money. So, would
you really think that doing more media
is the
solution? And so, they looked at me for
a second and I was like, what do you
sell to make your money? And they were
like,"Well, I mean, you know, we do
sponsorships every once in a while. We
basically this and that." I was like,
"Okay, do you think it's possible that
not having a clear monetization
mechanism is the issue? What would you
rate your monetization strategy at?" And
they're like, "Oh, well, probably like a
five out of 100." I was like, "Okay, so
you've been deploying all your resources
to go from 99 to 99.5%."
rather than taking those same resources.
And the thing is is that when you're
this low, going from five to like 25
probably takes less effort than going
from 99 to 99.5. And so what we need to
do is fix the monetization of this
business. When they had this larger
goal, the business that they thought
they were in, which is media, but to get
to where they want to go, they were
going to have to enter into having a
business model. They're going to have
enter into monetization as the issue in
the business. The problem that most
businesses have is they don't know the
business they're actually in and they
keep trying to solve the problem that
they enjoy solving rather than the one
that the business requires to be solved.
Every business has a big hairy problem
and this has been my experience and
maybe just because it took me too long
to learn or I you know I I I only learn
about it once I get into it as a
recommendation. So this is a a hack of
hacks. If you're entering a new
marketplace, talk to the people already
in that marketplace and ask them what
the hardest part of their business is.
And a lot of people follow me because
they're in education or consulting
information products. So think to
yourself, well, if you're in that world,
what business do you think you're really
in? Well, if you learn the basics of
marketing and sales, just like any
business, but if you want to make it
big, look at the big consulting firms.
Look at Mackenzie, look at Bane, look at
Ernston Young or KPMG. These are all
recruiting machines because on a long
enough time horizon, you have to learn
how to do other stuff because you can
only keep selling infinite people for a
period of time until eventually you've
sold everyone within a marketplace and
there's no one left. You've already
pillaged the land. Instead, we have to
find a way to get people to keep buying.
If it's in the service business, it
means having exceptional people. If it's
in a physical products thing, it's how
do we get customers to come back again
and again. If you're in the software
business, the same thing except you're
doing it via code rather than kind of a
recurring how do we basically engineer
consumption. A lot of entrepreneurs who
are in the education space, and I bring
this up because I'm literally educating
right now, is that they have one
talented person, they have some guru,
and then they hire people who really
aren't as good, and then they dilute the
service quality over time. And then
they're surprised that somehow their
business stops growing. When they were
smaller, you grew really fast because
you had a good product, which was you.
You were exceptional. And then you hired
all these other people, and they're not
exceptional. But then you're like, "Oh,
I love this one. I decided to stop doing
it because it's not scalable." One of my
favorite lines to
hear. I'm going to try not to curse.
It's going to be hard not to. I'm like
really
struggling, [__] They are
building cities in the middle of the
ocean. We are sending rockets to space
and building internet from satellites
globally. We have electric cars. We have
AI robots. and you think that you can't
scale
service. Of course, it's scalable.
You're just not good enough. But when
you phrase it that way, now it becomes a
problem that you can solve. This is a
second hack of hacks for figuring this
out. Insert the problem that you claim
to have that is unsolvable and frame it
in the form of an I don't know. So, for
example, no one can sell like me. I hear
this all the time. No one can sell like
me. What if you said, "I don't know how
to get anyone to sell like me.
Salespeople suck. I don't know how to
find good
salespeople. There's no good plumbers. I
don't know how to recruit, hire, and
train good plumbers. All the leads are
crap. I don't know how to advertise to
get good leads." One is a complaint, the
other is a question, and the question
has an answer. And so as soon as you can
actually ask the right question, you
start walking down the path to getting
the thing that your business actually
needs rather than you just complaining
and giving yourself an excuse for why
your business isn't growing anymore. And
then you cast all the power out to some
external thing. And that way you feel
good and you can rock yourself to sleep
every night saying, you know what, I
gave it the good fight. But there are
some people who actually want to [__]
win. And so for those people, who I'm
making this video for, the thing that
you're doing right now, if you keep
doing it and it's not working, is the
wrong thing. So let me give you one that
you might not know as much about. So in
the investing world, so I got into this,
right? So we Leila and I took out, you
know, tens many tens of millions of
dollars in distributions. Then we also
sold the company for lots of tens of
millions of dollars. And so we had
enough money that we could start our own
family office and actually start buying
companies and investing. I thought
investing was about doing lots of deals
at good prices. And what's interesting
about this is that in some businesses it
does work that way. So, like if you were
selling cars, a lot of times the price
of a Honda 2000, whatever is this
basically your proprietary way of
getting a commodity for less. You're not
going to get it by by jipping people on
the sale. Sure, you want to close at
retail or as close to it as possible,
but you're not going to buy a Honda and
then all of a sudden sell it for 100
grand. So, you're going to make more of
the money on where you buy and then you
make up the difference on the sale at
market rate. Whereas in the investing
world, and this is what like I thought
it functioned that way, but it assumed
businesses were commodities. Think about
this for a second. It assumed that okay,
I'm just going to try and buy as many
businesses as I can and buy them as for
as low as possible. But the problem I
was missing is that a really good
business can outperform all of your bad
ones with one good deal. For me, what I
thought I was in was the high volume
discount deals. The business that I was
really in was learning how to say no at
a much higher velocity to a much higher
number of deals because you only need
one Facebook. So, let's confront the
real problem. At each stage, I've had
these learning curves where I thought I
knew what the business was about and
then I realized what it was really
about. The big hairy problem that I had
to solve. Here's how I think through
this. It can be painful because
oftentimes we spend so much time trying
to solve every other problem that we
think we know how to solve rather than
solving the one that we know we need to
solve but don't know how to. That's a
lot of times what makes that big hairy
problem so hard is that you just don't
know what to do. And this is why so many
entrepreneurs start a second business
because they're like, I don't know how
to solve to grow this and past this one.
And then they make up a reason and then
they start another business because they
think somehow the second business is
going to be different than the first
when in reality you're just going to
reach a plateau that you don't know and
then you're going to stop again. So you
have to confront the issue. You have to
confront the problem. And so this is how
I mentally trick myself into getting to
being okay with solving hard problems
that I have no idea how to solve. I
imagine myself, let's just this is
purely hypothetical. All right, so let's
say that I've got a business that's
doing $10 million a year. You can use
whatever zeros you want. Okay? And let's
say that it's got, you know, $3 million
in profit. Okay? So this is topline.
This is bottom line, aka profit,
leftover cashola, cheese, cheddar,
lettuce, money in the bank account,
whatever you want to say. So that's our
top line, bottom line. Let's say that
we've got this big hairy
problem. So, we got this big hairy
problem. Now, we think that if we solve
this big hairy problem, we're going to
be able to continue to grow the business
to $20 million a year in topline
revenue. And that three because we've
covered a lot of our base, our fixed
costs in the 10 million is actually
going to jump all the way to like seven
or eight million. All right. In profit.
So, big a disproportionate profit
increase with the increase in topline,
which is not uncommon.
So, here's what's crazy. This business
might be worth somewhere in the
neighborhood of $15 million. I'm just
going to make an estimate that's a 5x on
this $3 million. Okay? Now, this $8
million business might be closer to
worth maybe like $72 million. That's
with a 9x. And so, the difference
between these two amounts is
$57 million.
That is a big a lot of dollars. Here's
how I mentally trick myself. I say,
"Man, this big hairy problem is big and
hairy."
But if someone paid me $57 million to
solve it, would I be willing to solve
it? I'm like, "Hell yeah, I'd probably
solve it for a million dollars." And so,
I've got this nice $56 million surplus
of what I'm willing to do it for versus
what it's actually worth. I tell our
founders in the in in the portfolio, I
say once once we figure out what this
big hairy problem is, I always try and
remember to do this and I say, "Hey, if
we do this, this is going to lock $50
million enterprise value. This is going
to lock $100 million in enterprise value
if we solve this one problem." There's a
common saying in the in the venture
capital world, which is, is this a
feature or is this a bug? There are some
businesses that I will see founders bang
their heads against the wall being like,
I have to solve the churn issue in my
gym. I have to get it so no one leaves.
I can tell you right now, you're never
going to solve churn in fitness. You're
not going to do it because it's a human
problem. It's not a bug. It's a feature.
We have to look at what are the features
of our business versus what are the bugs
of our business. The bugs of the
business are the things that you can and
should work on that can help you get to
the next level. The features of the
business is like this is the core way
this business works. If you know for a
fact that people are going to cancel
fitness, because let's face it, people
do, then what then becomes the issue? I
need to build a marketing machine so
that I never run out of people. Now, the
good news, couple pieces of good news if
you're in one of those businesses is
that one, some people come back into the
business, right? So, if people lose
weight or they don't lose weight in two
or three years, they might still want to
lose weight and try again. Whereas,
there's other companies, let's say your
uh your internet bill, probably haven't
switched providers in a while. Who does
your banking for you? You probably have
been with the same bank since you got a
Looney Tunes account when you were six.
And so you've probably had this around
the same banks for a while because it's
a pain to change and you probably don't
care that much about it. And so for
those businesses, they're all about
aggregating market share and just having
a really sticky customer base. But guess
what? They have problems too. My former
CFO gave me this piece of advice uh that
I just absolutely loved. And I was I was
griping to her one day about about
basically features of this business.
Like these are things that are
absolutely true about this business. And
I was basically just complaining because
there's nothing I can do about it. and
she said, "Alex, you know, I've been in
in business and I've seen a lot of
different businesses over my
career." She said, "The grass is always
greener on the other side because no one
sees that's fertilized
with." And she's like, "It's all they're
all every business has." But the idea is
that every business has overhead. Every
business has stuff that is features and
there's bugs. Things that are wrong with
your service that should get fixed and
things that are inherent to the very
nature of this business. There's core
features inherent to every business and
we just have to be able to confront the
issue that is at hand. And often times
it's big, it's hairy and it sucks. We
got to make sure that we're not trying
to spend all of our effort trying to fix
a term problem that will literally never
get fixed because you're trying to gas
humans to stop being human. If you think
about entrepreneurship as a video game,
which I often do. All right. So, let's
imagine that we've got these levels
here. All right. So, we've got level
zero. We got one, two, three, four,
five, six, whatever. I should probably
end on seven because seven feels like a
better level to end on, but let's let's
go with six. Maybe in the very
beginning, you have to figure out what
you're going to sell. All right? You've
got a what. And the big issue at this
point is that you just can't make
decisions. You're completely indecisive.
You can't commit to anything. You have
this fallacy of the perfect pick. You
think that that whatever you pick has to
be the one thing that you're going to
stick with the rest of your life. But
the reality is that you're probably not
because you don't even know what you're
doing, right? you don't have the
perspective from which to make a
judgment. And the only way you can gain
perspective in which to make a judgment
is to actually pick something and then
start and then gain more data. You have
to do that first. Now, let's say that
you graduate from that level and you
actually made a selection.
Congratulations. Now you have something
to sell. So then you have to learn
advertising 101 because no one's going
to buy your thing unless they know about
it, right? So you have to learn that
skill. At every one of these levels, you
will have entrepreneurs that just get to
level one and then they they don't learn
level two. Let's say that let's let's
say level two is they learn how to
profit. All right? They learn a business
model around it that that they they wrap
a business around it. Okay? Let's say
that's that's level two. Well, they get
to level one and then they say, "You
know what? I just saw this thing over
here that looks easier to scale up. So,
I'm going to I'm going to race through
level one and level two here." And they
do. And here's the crazy part. This next
business, they do this in onethird the
time. And they're like, "Oh, yeah. This
was a great idea. I just boom, look how
fast I'm going." and then they crash
into the same level again. They're still
stuck at level two because they never
learned it. The big hairy problem is
typically the problem that you need to
solve to get to the next level. And it
typically requires an entirely different
skill set. Most people can't confront
that level of uncertainty or that level
of dissatisfaction with themselves. And
so they just start something else. This
is and I will I will probably keep
repeating this because it it needs
repeating is that the woman in the red
dress. All right, she is the
distraction. And if you don't know what
I'm talking about, in the Matrix,
there's a moment where Morpheus is
training Neo. They're walking through a
busy city. Then all of a sudden, a woman
in a red dress walks by. Morpheus is
talking. Neo looks back. And then Morphe
says, "Were you listening to me or were
you looking at the woman in the red
dress?" And he looks back at him and he
says, "Look again." He looks again.
There's a gun pointed at him. And he
says, "Freeze." He said, "This whole
point, this training is to teach you one
thing, which is that if you're not one
of us, you're one of them. The one of us
is if it's not the core business, it is
a distraction from the core business."
Because every one of these other things,
every one of these other people in the
street, every one of these other
opportunities can look attractive
because you don't know the [__] on the
other side. It's the grass is greener
because it's on the other side of the
fence. that if you got close to it,
you'd see the manure that you had to sit
in in order to get it to grow. The
craziest part about all this is that you
can beat just about everyone if you can
stick with something for a few years.
Hey, and real quick, if you're not sure
what level of business you're at right
now, I spent 200 hours this year just
making this one project for you, which
is the $und00 million scaling road map.
And I broke up the stages of business
into 10 stages. And you can identify
where you're at by simply just putting
in your business information. You go to
acquisition.comroadmap and it'll spit
out this custom report that tells you
what the constraints are at that current
level and what you need to do to
graduate and get to the next level. This
is our gift to you absolutely free. And
if you're like, I'm not sure what the
big hair problem is or I'm not sure what
business I'm really in. On the thank you
page, you can book a call with our team
and we'd love to help you uh figure that
out and ideally get past it. Let me
conquer a big
belief that is common among
entrepreneurs. One of the biggest
reasons that people will switch from
their current business to the next
business. There's two big ones. One is a
fancy way of saying it's hard. This is
the like I don't think my business is
that scalable. And I'm like remember
cities middle of the ocean. Rocket ships
in space. Cars that drive themselves.
Robots that are smarter than
humans. Really? You think it's not
scalable or you don't know how to scale
it? Remember, let's flip it into a
question. I don't know how. I don't know
how to scale it. How do I scale a
business like mine? So one is a
difficulties thing. The other one that
they do is that they will say I don't
think this business can get to the size
that I want for myself. Now I will put a
big disclaimer here which is that if you
want to be the richest person in the
world, yes, you're going to probably
have to do some sort of technology that
has mass global appeal and it can't look
like any of the technology businesses
that already exist because those already
exist. So it has to be a true denovo
idea. And I'll tell you something else.
If your goal is to become a
trillionaire, you probably won't. And
the reason for that is because the
people who are the absolute richest in
the world are missionaries, not
mercenaries. They do it because they
genuinely believe that this solution
deserves to exist in the world and
they're willing to eat glass for a very
long time. Now, in your mind, and I say
this as also an entrepreneur who has
money goals, in your mind, a trillion
dollars is just like you you just see
that as winning because that means that
you're the richest person in the world.
But like, can you name the richest
person in the world 30 years ago? You
can't. It was that guy was number one.
Can't name him. It wasn't Bill Gates. Do
you know who Paul Getty was? Richest man
in the world 100 years ago. 30 years he
was richest man in the
world. You can't name him. So this idea
that you think of becoming the richest
man in the world is going to somehow
make you immune to impermanence. That
you're going to that your life is going
to now be meaningful because of that. It
won't be. And I can also tell you that
like a billion dollars is a lot of
money. A hundred billion dollars is a
lot of money. If you're not at that
level, like I think having that goal is
a bit silly because things will change
as resources change, the map and the
pieces in the board change as you
develop as an entrepreneur under the
assumption that you have what I would
consider to be modest goals of let's say
a hundred million. Let's say let's make
that our modest goal. All right, so bear
with me here. Every business in my
opinion can get to $100 million
enterprise value. I want to be clear
here. I'm not saying every entrepreneur
can get to $100 million. I'm not saying
every every business as it currently
stands can get to $100 million. I'm
saying that there is a version of every
business that's maybe adjacent or one or
two steps away that can absolutely
become it. So, let me give you an
example. I have a restaurant. I don't
think it's scalable and I don't think
that I can be a 100 millionaire. Well,
all we all we'd have to do to disprove
this is say, is there anyone who's worth
over a hundred million dollars in
restaurants? Turns out there is. There's
actually a ton of them. In fact, my
neighbor above me is worth a
dec 10 billion and he owns restaurants.
Uh the guy who started Subway, who's the
primary owner of Subway, one is a
franchise model, the other is privately
held. Okay, so you wait, so I definitely
have to do you can do either of them,
but you have to pick which one you're
going to do, and you have to go all in
for a period long period of time. And
you might be like, well, yeah, sure,
Subway. Well, let's let's play a fun
game. How old do you think Subway is?
59 years old as of right now me making
this video. How long do you think uh
Andrew Churn and Peggy Churn of Panda
Express have been doing Panda Express?
years. And so you're right. The five
years you've been making your restaurant
is probably not that close to the 59
years that Subway has. And you're like,
"Oh, well maybe I'll be like Chick-fil-A
78 years." Can a restaurant business
become a billion-dollar business as fast
as a software company or technology
company?
No. But what did we say your goal was?
You said 100 million bucks. That means
you have to get about $10 million in
profit in the business between now and
the time you
die. Doable. That's not a promise.
That's not a guarantee. I'm just saying
it's doable. Even if you're like, "Okay,
well, I have a dry cleaning business."
Okay. Well, we can make that into a
franchise model and then scale that way.
We can privately own them and just keep
compounding the the business. And what
is what's the what business are we
really in when we're in dry cleaning?
Honest truth, I don't know. I've never
been in it. What I would do is I'd talk
to a bunch of dry cleaning people, what
sucks the most about the business? Maybe
talent's not that hard in dry cleaning
because maybe the the skills of maning a
dry cleaning business are not that
tough. Maybe the issue is the machines
break a lot and you're actually like,
"Actually, I'm in the logistics and, you
know, machining business. I need a lot
of tech inside of that business." Okay.
Well, that's the business you're in. Ask
people who are in the business what the
hardest part of it is. Oftentimes
they'll give you the big hairy problem
and then you just get to say is that the
type of problem that I'd prefer to
solve. And this is a frame that Leila
uses a lot that I love when we're when
we're helping an entrepreneur make a big
a big decision. They'll say hey there's
these two paths I have in front of me
and I'm not sure should I do the
franchise, should I do the private held
model right now. The big overarching
thing that no one seems to mention
is we might ask what's the goal? But
what the subtext underneath of that is
in what timeline? Because almost all
goals are accomplishable on a long
enough timeline. Now, back to the two
paths. Let's say that you're making that
decision. I want to I want to start a
franchise or I want to keep privately
held. Okay, if this is the path, what
you want to do is you want to adequately
be able to know what the big hairy
problem is in each of those paths
because there's one and they're
different.
And then you ask the followup question
which is which of these problems would I
rather
have? Followup to that is which problem
do I feel more equipped to solve today?
And so that gives you a lot of insight
because a lot of times people want to
think about the upside but the downside
mitigation is what gets you to the
upside. Elon has this really great quote
that he has from somebody else but he
says entrepreneurship is a lot like
staring into the abyss and eating glass.
The staring in the bis part is because
you're constantly facing the uncertainty
of the business and existential risk to
the business every single day feeling
like it might not work. On the eating
glass side, it's that entrepreneurship
is the most efficient funnel for having
nothing but bad news. So think about it
like this. There are problems that are
very hard to solve and there are
problems that people don't want to
solve. You get to have the best of both.
As in you get problems that no one wants
to solve and they're really hard, right?
Problems that are hard that people want
to solve, they'll still work on them for
you. Uh problems that are easy that
people don't want to do, ah you can
usually pay someone enough, but like
it's solvable. But it's the ones that
really suck and no one wants that you
get to have. And what happens is this
becomes your lens of the world because
you just think all day every day is
problems that absolutely blow and no one
wants to do that. But you have to do it
because who else is going to do it? It's
your business. Every single day it's
just trudging through this muck. And you
think that somehow another business is
going to have different mechanics. But
this is a feature of entrepreneurship,
not a bug. Entrepreneurship is the
mechanics of entrepreneurship and
ownership, specifically being CEO, being
the person who's calling the shots.
That's your life and that's what you get
compensated for. And so there's a lot of
romanticism about entrepreneurship. The
freedom that entrepreneurship gives you.
Well, it depends how big you want to go.
Because basically the day that you stop
eating glass, the day that you you you
stop dealing with that is the day that
in my opinion you sacrifice somebody for
potential for comfort. And I think
that's okay. I think it's totally okay.
But that's a trade you get to choose to
make. But at the end of the day, I said
that there was two big reasons that
people say, "I think I should switch my
business." One is that the business I
have is currently not scalable.
Hopefully, I've popped that balloon for
you. And the other is that I don't think
that this thing could become super big.
Well, we have to ask the question, how
big? And why do you want it to be that
big? Is if it's just for you go, you're
probably never going to make it because
it's too hard and you already have
satisfied your material needs. So, the
reason that those massive companies
exist is because the people who started
them genuinely thought that it's almost
like their purpose in life was to do
this service for the world. And as a
result, the company continued to grow
and they were willing to deal with all
the glass for that entire period of
time. We talk about Jeff Bezos with
Amazon. You know, it's only just been
like a chill 30 years for Amazon,
35. Like we talk about these fast growth
tech like Facebook's like 20some years
old. At the end of the day, you're going
to have this choice. I want you to know
that there is absolutely a version of
your business that can become $100
million. I really genu like I have a
very hard time having someone convince
me that there's not a version of just
about any business because there's
because because of
this, no matter how small the niche is,
there's eight billion people in the
world. And so with online, we can now
access them. This might not have been
true 30 years ago, but today it kind of
is. Anything brick and mortar, you can
scale nationally. Now, if you're like,
well, I'm in a country that only has
seven seven people. Okay. Well, then
guess what? You become international.
But are you saying it's impossible or
difficult? Want to make sure we're clear
here. I don't know how to go
international. Do you think no one else
has gone international before? Oh,
people have done it. Therefore, it is
possible. Therefore, I can learn it. I
think about these big hairy problems
because this is what hopefully the
entire point of this video is figuring
out the business you're really in and
being able to confront the problem ahead
of you so that you don't switch paths
and you actually solve the thing that
gets you to the next level. While you're
going through this, I think that there's
this personal experience that you have
to learn the difference between which is
what's good hard and what's bad. And
this actually ladders up to a very
classic entrepreneurial question of do I
push or do I pivot? And you're like,
wait a second, I thought you said that
uh I shouldn't switch new things. It's
different. The good kind of hard is when
you have underlying assumptions that you
believe to be true from first principles
and just have to push through via
iteration. That sounded like a bunch of
words. So, let me just give you an
example. So, if I want to start running
TikTok ads for one of our companies
because we we decide like you know what,
one of the things the big hairy problem
here is that we don't know how to
advertise on paid and that's what's
that's what it's going to take for us to
unlock. Okay. Well, if I sell to
accountants, right, I would say okay,
are there accountants on TikTok? And the
answer would be yes. And so it's like,
okay, well, is there a way that we can
run ads profitably to get our messaging
in front of those people? If the answer
is yes, then I fundamentally believe
that there's a profitable way to turn
those eyeballs into customers. Period.
Now, you might have run a Tik Tok ad to
get accountants and not gotten them. But
it doesn't mean that getting accountants
on TikTok is impossible. It's just you
don't know how to do it. Again,
solvable. And you might be like, "Ah,
but that's going to be hard." Remember,
there's going to be a big dollar sign, a
big price tag associated with solving
that problem. Let's say if we we start
running ads and we don't immediately see
ROI. That's the good kind of art because
we can iterate. Remember I said good
kind is you iterate, right? Do we get
enough clicks? Do we get enough optins?
Are they the people who opt in are the
right type of people? If not, maybe we
need to change the messaging, change the
targeting, right? All these are just
iterative. But it's not that it's
impossible. It's just it takes work.
This is iterative hard. That's good
hard. To be clear, I don't see losing
money on ads as losing money. I see it
as investing in something that's going
to increase the enterprise value by
creating another acquisition channel and
simultaneously diversifying how we get
customers. And so having multiple
acquisition channels meaningfully
increases enterprise value without even
having additional profit because it
decreases the risk for the acquirer as
in the person who's going to buy the
company. Right? If I have two ways of
getting customers, I feel way better. If
I had six ways of getting customers, I
feel even better than that. But not only
that, each of the six ways also brings
more customers. So it also grows the
business and decreases the risk. It's
one of the most valuable things you can
do in a business. And so it would make
sense that the reason it's such a
valuable thing to do in the business is
because it's hard. It's hard. It's why
most people don't do it, which is why it
is valuable and it is rare. I can't say
that I want this really rare outcome and
then at the same breath say I'm not
willing to do very rare levels of work.
So let's let's do a hypothetical. So if
a business is worth $10 million, okay,
and I can add a second acquisition
channel that doubles the revenue and
diversifies the risk, that might add $15
million enterprise value. So, if I lose
$100,000 figuring out Tik Tok ads over
six months, but I get a $10 million
return on
it, would I do
it? Absolutely. But the thing is is I
say this and people nod their heads or
they're listening and they're like,
"Yeah, I believe that." But you have to
see these as investments in the
business. like I'm going to invest this
time and this money and I am willing to
not see success for this period of time
before deciding to truly call it. And
honestly the when you decide to truly
call it is just your ability to deal
with pain. So there's something about
human behavior around this which comes
down to frustration tolerance. So the
basic behavior is how many times you try
something again before you quit and this
typically has to do with your history of
being reinforced after multiple
attempts. So I'll give you a very simple
example. If you say, "Hey, I'm not going
to buy something from you." And the
salesman says, "Well, like, have you
thought about it like this or have you
thought about like that?" The amount of
times that that salesman is willing to
both follow up and ask again on the call
is directly proportional to the amount
of times in his past or her past that
after asking a second, third, fourth,
fifth time, they were rewarded for doing
so. And so, if someone gets rewarded,
again, intermittent reinforcement
doesn't mean they have to get reinforced
every time they ask five times. If they
get reinforced enough times that they
ask five times, they will ask five times
every time. So if you have a dog and
they come to the table and you give them
food because they beg, right? Then what
do you do? You reinforce begging. So
they come back and they beg. Now if they
come back and then you don't give it to
them because you execute your willpower
and they sit there and they're like and
they you still don't give them food.
Fine. What do they do tomorrow? They
come back
again. And what do you do tomorrow? You
don't give it to them. What do they do
the next day? They come back again.
Okay, they come back again. And here's
the crazy part. Let's say that let's say
that they come back five, six times. If
on the sixth time you give it to them
again, you've just taught them that they
have to wait for extended periods of
time. You've rewarded them trying again
and again and again and again.
Entrepreneurs, we are like this too. And
if you're newer to the game, then I
would encourage you to increase your
frustration tolerance. can't manufacture
the win that you're going to have, but
this is why I try to make these videos
is that the amount of times that it has
taken me a hundred iterations to get an
ad campaign to work is a lot. And so now
I just have a fundamental belief. I'm
like, if we keep working on this, we
will make this work because down to
fundamentals, there are eyeballs here
and we can pay to to reach them. And
there's no reason physically why we
can't get them to take a click and then
ultimately buy our thing. We just aren't
good enough. And so we just have to
look, are there people who could buy my
stuff on this platform? Is there a way
to reach them? And can I do this
profitably? Yes. Great. Then we will
make money on a long enough time
horizon. And so the only thing we have
to do is just not run out of money while
we try. That's it. But here's the thing.
Let's say that and I said I said that
this is what this looks like in reality.
You make this decision to make this
investment because you see the big price
tag on the other side, right? And you
say it would be reasonable for me to
spend $100,000, a million dollar,
whatever the number is for you in six
months to get this thing that's going to
double our acquisition, right? Of course
you would make that investment. But the
first month you spend a hundred grand
and then you don't make money back.
People throw their hands up and they're
like, "Ah, it doesn't work for me." Of
course it didn't work the first time.
This is why you get paid to solve big
problems. The types of problems that
occur in entrepreneurship is they're all
one of a kind. And you're like, "Wait a
second. I thought business behaving
patterns." Absolutely. So, I think
there's this great uh, you know, like
history doesn't repeat itself, but it
rhymes. It's the same thing in business.
Like if I knew every single thing that I
was going to do with every business that
I started of, then it would be instant,
right? you'd be instantly instantly
bigger. But no, there's similarities.
There's patterns that you recognize, but
you're like, "Okay, we're going to have
to turn on paid ads, but we've never
done this for B2B on Tik Tok. So, we're
going to have to learn that little
nuance in this setting." And even if
you've done B2B on Tik Tok, maybe you
haven't done B2B on Tik Tok for
accounting, but you did it for for for
marketing agencies, right? So, like,
okay, fine, we did that. All right.
Well, like there's always going to be
more nuance because I can always say,
cool. Well, you did that a year ago, but
what about today? So the idea that
you're going to know the solution is is
a false belief that will make
entrepreneurship significantly harder
for you or at least more painful for
you. I said earlier in this little diet
tribe that I just went on, there's good
kind of hard and there's bad kind of
hard. So what's bad kind of hard? Bad
kind of hard is when your underlying
assumptions are proven incorrect. So
this is the classic push or pivot,
right? So if we've pivoted several
times, but I've pushed a lot more. So
you pivot when your underlying
assumptions are proven incorrect.
Meaning so let's say for example if a
report came out saying Tik Tok had
banned accountants from the platform
then I would say we don't push on Tik
Tok. The underlying assumption was there
are people here we can reach them
profitably. Well the underlying
assumption is wrong. That's not true. So
at that point we have to pivot to a
different platform or different
advertising method. And so I just use
this as a clear test of when I'm being
stubborn versus when I'm being
intelligent. And so before making a big
investment, I like to identify what I
call the need to believes, right? Or the
assumptions that I believe to be true or
must believe to be true in order for the
remainder to follow as desired, right?
So as long as those assumptions are
true, we keep pushing. And if one of
those assumptions is proven wrong with
supporting data, then you change. And so
fundamentally, that's the ignorance tax
we all pay is that sometimes you have
these assumptions because you can't know
everything. You're not God. Can't know
everything. Sometimes you got to find
out on your own. and you find out that
assumption that I had is not true. And
that was kind of like the whole thing
this was predicated on. And so then you
pivot. You find something else out that
is true that you didn't know was true
before. And then you make your change. I
tell the story in my $100 million offers
book of good friend of mine who had a
technology business. So you think, oh
technology, this is something that, you
know, obviously it's going to be cutting
edge. But what he chose to do was try
and turn around a dying industry. So he
tried to turn around newspapers. So, we
said, "Hey, I'm going to take you into
the digital age, and we're going to have
an ad product for you that'll take all
your print ads and turn them into online
ads on your site." And it's just, you
know, you can use our software to do it.
It's one click, whatever. It's very
easy. With that, you think, okay, that
business makes sense. You're going to
transition these guys over. It gives
them a whole another thing that they can
sell. Cool. Groovy. Now, what was the
problem with the business? What are the
need to believes in that business? The
need to believes are that newspapers
with their inherent business model are
going to continue to exist in order for
that business to be viable. Now, at the
onset, you might get into that business
thinking, well, yeah, I'm going to help
them convert. That makes sense. But if
those businesses cease to exist, there
is no one left to convert because all
the people have just switched their
consumption to other platforms. And so,
in that instance, that's what I consider
bad hard. That's like the underlying
assumption of this business is no longer
true. It's proven incorrect. We thought
that they would continue to exist. We
could flip them over and they'd generate
the same revenue as they were before.
And so then we'd have this massive
market to go after. But in reality, many
of them just went out of business. And
so there's really no one to go after.
The few that did that you could go after
continue to shrink over time. Not a good
market to go after. That is a bad heart.
It's the kind of hard that you can't
fix. In that setting, you have to pivot.
He would then have to ask the question,
okay, what other businesses could I add
digital ads to? And then at that point,
you'd have to say, okay, maybe I could
take blogs and make ads, make it make a
network of blogs and that's kind of more
new age traffic and help them either
cross- sell across each others and, you
know, basically create this network of
traffic. Like that would be an
interesting business. Again, there'd be
need to around that as well. At that
point, you'd have to have a real
existential question of like who do we
want to be when we grow up? Because who
we thought we wanted to be ain't going
to work out. Little little subtext here.
It's very rare in what I would consider
traditional businesses to have a need to
believe that's actually not true. If
you're an accountant, you're in lawn
care, you're in your plumbing business,
you're you sell, you know, website
design, notwithstanding AI for the for
the time being and robots taking over.
Notwithstanding those two things, for
the last however many years, 50, 60, 80
years, those businesses, more or less,
you not being able to scale them was a
you problem. It was fundamentally you
didn't know how. That was it. There
wasn't anything wrong with the market.
There's nothing wrong with HVAC. There's
nothing wrong with plumbing, nothing
wrong with lawn care. All those things
are going to continue to exist. And so,
if you were limited in what any kind of
business that I would consider a normal
business, just know that there's nothing
to do with the scalability of your
business. It's your ability to scale
that is the problem. Yours. And so at
the end of the day, a lot of
entrepreneurs get into this for some
sort of freedom or some sort of monetary
goal or because they want to solve a
problem or a combination of all three.
But we fundamentally get paid to solve
big hairy problems. And the bigger and
hairier the problem in general, the
bigger and harrier the payoff. Paul
Graham said this quote on Twitter the
other day and I really liked it. He
said, "If you want to make a million
dollars, you must endure a million
dollars of pain. I like to consider how
much enterprise value I'll get on the
other side of this concrete wall than to
bash my head into. If the number is big
enough and I've got a strong enough
helmet, I will keep bashing into it so I
can get to the other side. And that's
what keeps motivating me. So, as long as
I'm solving the right kinds of problems,
the ones where I can reason to first
principles that there is a solution. And
that solution will make money, then I
keep going. And if I get to the bottom
of it and I find out that my underlying
assumption is wrong, I have to change.
And that's just as hard. For the
entrepreneurs who are stuck, who are
listening to this, who are watching
this, identify the business that you're
really in. Confront the big hairy
problem in front of you. Don't jump ship
thinking that some reason the grass is
greener or that the woman in the red
dress is somehow different and not crazy
from the woman that you're married to
right now. She just has a different kind
of crazy and you'll discover that in
time. So, you might as well be happy
with the one you got because you know
what you need to do to make this person
happy and you keep forging. And then you
decide whether or not you want to push
or you want to pivot based on the
underlying assumptions. And if you push,
focus on making progress and breaking
through that wall because the payoff is
on the other side and that's what makes
entrepreneurship worthwhile. Now, this
was all very theoretical because, you
know, obviously it applies to a lot of
different businesses. If you want to see
me apply these same concepts of how to
actually push through the walls for a
business to get it to break through to
the next level, I have a video here that
you're absolutely going to love of me
breaking down a real business and
helping them scale.